I'll let you uh explain you know what
this is but it's showing in my
understanding that the money going from
the there is no money now flowing from
the Federal Reserve uh in into the
treasury so could you give us an
explanation of what the situation with
the FED is right now and how it's
different from you know uh you know
anything in our our memory of of what's
been going on with the Fed
sure the Federal Reserve uh you know as
Arnold point out does have a similar
problem to a lot of these banks with the
key difference being that they can't do
a bank run on the Central Bank
um and so basically it's it's in a
position where you know they raise their
liability side uh interest rates much
higher uh compared to their asset side
which are longer duration fixed rate
assets and so you know for for most of
the FED history you know their
liabilities are things like banknotes
which don't pay any interest Bank
Reserves
um anniversary posts and then their
asset side is mostly treasuries and
mortgage-backed securities and those are
longer duration assets and so for most
of fed history for decades
um you know their assets pay a higher
average interest rate than their
liabilities and so they they make a
profit they cover their expenses and
then they send the remaining to the
treasury as a remittance
um whereas what we've seen since
September of last year was that because
they raised their interest rate side so
quickly now their liabilities are paying
a higher interest rate than their assets
actually worse than most banks because
most banks you know if look at their
deposit rates they're nowhere near as
high as current interest rates
whereas the feds are so actually the FED
is operating at a loss and it has
something like a trillion dollars in in
unrealized losses uh with a key
difference being that you know you know
those like that liability side can't go
anywhere it can't get rapidly pulled
down uh the the main kind of downside
from that is that the treasury is no
longer getting their remittances anymore
and even if the FED would become
profitable in the future they still get
to pay themselves back uh before they
would resume those remittances so it's
basically contributing to the the fiscal
budget deficit and if we go back to the
prior question of you know who's to
blame here you know a lot of you see a
lot of people say just blaming the fed
or just blaming that bank and it's just
kind of a mix of a lot of factors
because the Federal Reserve did create a
very difficult operating environment
when you have say a rapid increase in
the amount of broad money supply uh very
low interest rates and you know when
asked about the rapid increase in the
broad money supply the the Federal
Reserve chairman said he didn't really
see this being inflationary
um then of course it was inflationary
and then they you know they had they had
to Pivot their whole monetary policy
they raised rates they also sucked
liquidity back out of the the banking
system uh and so basically banks are
undergoing this gigantic whipsaw uh that
is just a difficult operating
environment to work through but then of
course some banks manage that risk
better than others uh so there are banks
that manage their duration risk uh very
well and they also choose their
depositors I mean it's a choice for
Silicon Valley Bank to go after those
big business depositors that are that
are more of a Flight Risk and it was
their choice to invest almost
exclusively in long duration assets
which have bigger price swings and so I
it's certainly the case that that bank
made severe errors of judgment in terms
of risk management but it's also the
case it's just across the banking sector
it is just a more challenging
environment to operate in when you have
kind of record swings in interest rates
and uh you know just overall cash on the
system you know Bank deposits across the
country went up pretty significantly in
2020 and 2021 because of the stimulus to
be a big increase in the money supply uh
but some banks got more deposits than
others because they were more like a hot
area so for example Silicon Valley Bank
at a bigger rise in its deposits than
the typical bank because Tech startups
were a very big you know uh thing in
that period and they did invest in those
long duration assets so what makes it
you know where that that chart you just
pulled up that shows how it's very
different than 2008 because 2008 the
problem was that so many banks made bad
loans uh and they had very little
exposure to cash and treasuries which
are considered some of their safer
assets uh and they were instead were
heavily involved in in subprime mortgage
and a lot of those defaulted this time
it shows that the in some ways it's the
opposite problem they hold very very
safe assets uh it's just that the prices
of those assets went against them in a
silicon Valley's case they made a very
big bet on duration so Banks had to
invest their deposits their new deposits
somewhere and there's some banks like
JPMorgan that were conservative and they
mostly kept in short duration types of
assets whereas Silicon Valley Bank made
a very big bet on those longer duration
assets and so if you look at Banks
across the board Silicon Valley Bank had
unrealized losses on their on their
Securities that that you know roughly
equaled their total Capital meaning that
if they if they had to have a bank run
and have to sell those assets for a loss
uh you know depositors might not get
every every dollar back and you know the
thing is if they can hold those assets
to maturity
um you know some of them are are can't
default other ones have a very very low
default risk but if they get their their
deposit funding pulled and they have to
sell a loss then they basically you know
that gets marked to Market and they have
a problem and the the last point I'll
make is that um you know because FDIC
insurers deposits up to 250 000. you
know a typical bank that just has a lot
of retail deposits that's a pretty solid
deposit base because people are not
going to freak out too much if they if
they think their bank has a problem
whereas the issue with Silicon Valley
Banks they had a higher than normal
percentage of uninsured deposits and
that's because most of their depositors
were businesses so there are some
businesses that would hold even tens of
millions of dollars in an account you
know the average deposit was not that
big but they you know they could be half
a million could be a million could be a
million and a half it could be 5 million
and so if they perceive that combination
of high unrealized losses which Silicon
Valley Bank had more of than normal and
they have the combination of mostly
uninsured deposits which which again
Silicon Valley Bank was a standout then
that's a prime target for a bank run
because people have a greater incentive
to pull out and then it causes the
problem if you look back in the 1940s
which was the last time that federal
debt the GDP was as high as it is now
Banks did become basically these
vehicles where just a lot of government
debt was was monetized in there and
that's it's unfortunately kind of common
to happen in countries that have this
level of deficit and debt spending where
the banks essentially become like
utilities uh in that regard we've also
seen as a multi-decade trend of Bank
consolidation uh you know it
used to be like tens of thousands of
banks now there's like four thousand
Banks the top 10 banks have like half of
all assets uh right now there's a
deposit of flight from small Banks to
Big Banks so that's it's a continuing
Trend I'm curious to ask Lynn about
um you know the what you think about the
future of banking and um there's you've
argued in
uh let me pull it up here um
there's you've said that ironically
Regulators want Banks to be reasonably
safe but not too safe and that there's
this kind of deeper question that
nobody's really talking about which is
one way to to avoid Bank runs would
actually to just be to hold more cash
reserves but that because of the way
that um the the Federal Reserve and um
the FDIC and just banking regulation
works it's a lot harder to set up and
get a an approved Charter if you run a
bank that way one example of that is
custodia bank which I'm showing here
which I believe holds actually over it
holds like 108 of its res of its
deposits in cash so people can always
get the bank or always get their money
out um theoretically and
they pay they they fund this through
fees instead of
um you know uh loans so could you talk a
little bit about that that issue uh Len
of um fractional Reserve banking yeah
there have been a number of attempts
over the years for people to try to
create full Reserve Banks
um where you know instead of having just
a percentage of deposits uh in cash they
would have uh you know at least 100 of
deposits in cash and and you know one of
the main examples was the narrow Bank uh
you know these start as as state Charter
Banks and what they what they do is they
apply to have access to the Federal
Reserve and the narrow Bank basically
just you know they wanted to take
deposits and then put them on deposit
with the FED as a bank reserve and
therefore from a from a depositor's
perspective you just have like you know
you'd be basically banking with the
Federal Reserve except you'd have a thin
layer of of administrative overhead
between you and the FED because they'd
be operating you know the basic banking
services that you need
um and their their um application was
kind of held in in stasis for a number
of years uh there's been course or you
know core things over that it's like
ironically they're trying to make from a
depositor perspective about as safest
Bank you can make but they they get
criticized as it contributing to
systemic problems because then it could
suck deposits out from fraction Reserve
Banks towards that one uh at least for
certain types of depositors and then the
more recent case just this past year was
custodia Bank
um led by Caitlin Long and they want to
do more than just that but they're but
from the depositor perspective they do
plan they plan on putting 108 of
deposits uh at the Fed so that they
could withstand 100 Deposit Bank Run if
it were to occur again they would do
other services on the side but in terms
of that deposit and and what they do
with it uh and and they were also held
for a long time in stasis and then
ultimately denied
um and so and there's been other
attempts like that another kind
countries too and in a low interest rate
environment they'd have to try you know
they'd have to charge deposit or some
sort of fee to for those services in the
current environment they actually
wouldn't have to because Banks get paid
pretty high interest rates on their
reserves and so they could essentially
cover that overhead with those and then
even even potentially pass
um some deposit uh interest on to
depositors
um yeah and it's just it's not something
that the Federal Reserve has wanted to
exist for a variety of reasons hey
thanks for watching that excerpt from my
conversation with Lynn Alden and Arnold
cling about the Silicon Valley Bank
meltdown and what caused it who's to
blame what to expect next for the U.S
banking sector uh you can watch the full
conversation by clicking here or on the
link in the description below and
subscribe to reason TV and watch these
conversations live every Thursday at 1
pm Eastern